it is important that our SMEs and
startups face no purveyors to scale up
and enter new markets in the future by
mere 2018 we should adopt the electronic
communication code and clarify state
date rules for the compensation of
current users of the necessary spectrum
for 5g by me 2019 we should have
technical decisions to ensure that
necessary spectrum for the 5g will be
available by the end of 2020 there
should be at least one city in each
member state with 5g connectivity by
2020 to the 700 megahertz pand
is available in all Member States the
final roll out of the falchion network
is planned by the year 2025 when I wish
to have the 5g network available at
least in all major cities and transport
roads across the entire you we achieved
a channeler approach on the Parekh
regulation my team has worked hard to
ensure that regulators of electronic
communication sector are able to
cooperate efficiently and I am happy
that the member states showed strong
consensus today we also took note on the
core progress made on the a privacy
regulation the complexity of the
questions illustrates the importance of
the file sucrose Akiba Clemmie Montreuil
killing Volante booty imposition camino
conse avala fan de l'année satan second
opponent neo no transmission Davao Anika
avec la paramour open D sylheti diminish
wit